[Music]
you're spectacular in yours Alex you're
the best thing that's ever happened to
me
let's go the distance think of them as
well thought out suggestions every woman
has a list she just wrote it done no
woman would give a guy a list like this
unless she wanted to be with him for the
rest of her life
this could be good strategically you
ready to go to work eggshell white what
about polar bear that might be a bit too
dingy para something the locals are too
nebulous white teeth whitening comes
last
this is going to be very interesting may
I introduce dr. Antonio Rosenblatt oh
wow look at him please please take me
for a ride in your European cars I think
you'd have won all this great
relationship to all time
I'm doing the best I can with this
stupid list no nose when it starts to
care
you will need to be circumcised word of
advice stay soft my parents having stirs
my grandpa Carter my parents are having
sex with my grandparents drinker I'm
game who's gonna be your best man
[Music]
you